alors que le reportage du 12 45 de m6
faisait état des soirées clandestines
organisé par un célèbre collectionneur
très vite les internautes ont fait un
rapprochement avec pierre-jean chalands
sont contactés par leurs médias il avait
fini par reconnaître l'organisation de
ces soirées par le prisme de son avocat
hier dans tpm paix ce même pierre jean
chalencon vous expliquer alors qu'il
organisait effectivement des rencontres
mai à 17h30 et en nombre limité j'achète
sauf que voilà ce matin le
collectionneur était en direct sur bfm
télé et a totalement fait machine
arrière
il a alors expliqué que tout ça était en
fait un poisson d'avril c'était un
énorme poisson d'avril
un poisson d'avril qui a marché de son
côté gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur a expliqué avoir ouvert une
enquête sur cette affaire
finalement il avait menti il s'est
rétracté après l'ouverture d'une enquête
pour ce faire une fausse publicité
m'enfin je crois que publicité qui peut
lui coûter cher qu'une chose est sûre
l'ancien chroniqueur d'affaires conclut
semble s'être mis dans un sacré pétrin
alors vierge en chalencon at il menti
[Musique]
bien manger en soit il menti et
pierre-jean chalencon est avec nous en
face time et pierre-jean chalencon il
vit des moments difficiles alors après
voilà t'il comme il ne rend pas mais
c'est vrai qu'il y lit il est au bout de
ça dit pierre jean merci d'être là
pierre jean merci père jean chalencon
merci la syrie alors c'est vrai qu'en ce
moment
pierre-jean c'est c'est compliqué pour
toi avec cette polémique est ce que tu
peux nous dire ce soir j'ai vraiment
envie qu'on ait toute la vérité même
pour toi comme ça vraiment tu passe à
autre chose parce que c'est vrai que ça
prend des ampleurs incroyable cette
affaire déjà
est-ce que tu comprends que ces images
aient choqué ces images sont tombés
voilà je suis mais bien entendu comment
tu veux que ça ne me choque pas dire sur
moi et moi même j'aurais été choqué un
montage un montage comme ça montage
comme ça c'est totalement choquant bien
entendu j'aurais été le premier choqué
parce que alors hier donc dans touche
pas à mon poste
tu nous disais qu'il y avait neuf
invités dans cette soirée et ce matin
jean marc morandini
avec une source
une source anonyme chez jean-marc donné
une tout autre version il parlait de 40
personnes
alors vous avez vu ses membres oui oui
père jean excuse moi ça écoute non pas
du tout cette soirée enfin lé 9
personnes y avait neuf personnes y en a
des 40 il faut dire la vérité maljean
jetons plus il y en avait neuf ou y en
avait 40 des personnes je t'en penses tu
entends pas y en avait pas 40 se
déclarer et au maximum écoute ya dû
avoir une quinzaine ou une vingtaine de
personnes au maximum
c'était pas une soirée ce n'est pas une
soirée cet état a comment dirais-je un
rendez vous une présentation pour le bal
pour le palais vivienne pour les soirées
du retour de napoléon pahlevi viennent
puisque tu sais que j'organise pour le
bicentenaire de la mort de napoléon un
certain nombre de choses et que j'avais
prévu après confirmant que nous fassions
visiter à des entreprises à des aussi
les particuliers le palais vivienne avec
une petite restauration il avait
traversé une vague donc avec le crash
d'aldo personnes m'ont cyrille louis
pierchon pas ça le buzz de cette
histoire celle que j'ai fait de l'humour
et quelques malheureusement l'humour
j'ai l'impression qu'en france bat on la
comprend plus donc j'ai je sais que je
fais partie de l'académie alphonse
allais et alphonse allais et bien humour
sec et froid comme moi et j'ai
simplement lancé à une journaliste une
journaliste vendredi quand elle m'a
appelé
sans savoir d'ailleurs que cette
conversation secrète enregistrés ce qui
est totalement interdit et qui est
passible de la loi je crois je porterai
juin sujet là eh bien j'ai dit écoutez
bien entendu jeudi de même avec des
ministres pour tous les soirs ont des
restaurants clandestins bon c'était une
boutade bien entendu alors il ya un
moment il faut il faut arrêter il faut
arrêter tout ça et si jamais si j'avais
pas eu cette boutade
on en aurait pas parlé je tiens et je le
répète à toi mon ami cyril je n'ai pas
reçu de mini ou quel que soit quelques
personnes de corps ne ment depuis la fin
de ce
confinement alors justement il ya une 6
qui a répondu l'association des sociétés
des journalistes m6 a décidé de répondre
à tes propos pierre-jean sur bfm tv et
il confirme bien qu'un membre du
gouvernement à participer au dîner de
pierre-jean monsieur chalencon qui n'en
est pas à une contradiction près affirme
que ses propos étaient un énorme poisson
d'avril
or sur ce point d'autres sources ont
confirmé en off la présence d'au moins
un membre du gouvernement à un de ces
dîners nous poursuivons nos
investigations à ce sujet et il se
confirme bien qu'il y avait une
quarantaine de personnes à ce dîner
pierre-jean chalencon indique également
qu'il n'y avait qu'une dizaine de
personnes à sa soirée nous maintenons
qu'il y avait une quarantaine de
personnes comme le montrent les images
que nous nous sommes procurées nous
maintenons également que contrairement à
ce qu'il vit l'entrée était payante
notre enregistrement le prouve également
père jean qu'est ce tu réponds à cette
réponse de m6 écoute c'est de
l'acharnement médiatique j'ai
l'impression que ils veulent vraiment
faire sauter le gouvernement
et bien non je suis désolé il n'y avait
pas deux membres du gouvernement chez
moi c'est veut donner une grande
importance je le répète je le dis il n'y
avait pas de membre du gouvernement de
cette présentation est faite je ne fais
pas de soirée ça fait 15 mois cyril que
je suis sans malheureusement pouvoir
organiser des soirées ou quoi que ce
soit au palais du yen c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que j'avais organisé jeudi
dernier cette présentation à 17h30
et oui je vais appeler ça un poisson
d'avril parce que c'était le premier
abri perdu est ce que c'était payant une
agence que c'était payant parce qu'on a
vu 220 euros
c'était payant ou pas rien ce qu'ils
soient je t'entends
est-ce que c'était payant au maire d'ax
oui j'ai pas fait payer j'ai fait pays
qui plus personne donc parce que nous
invite les gens ils payent pardon refusé
alors dit moi on a l'impression ce que
je dois aider tous les ministres s'en
sont mêlés on a l'impression que c'est
une affaire d'état que tout le monde a
peur d'être associée cette liste noire
gilbert délé pierre-jean excusez moi
mais vous jouez sur les mots vous dites
moi je n'ai pas fait payer mais selon
mes informations moi j'ai les menus
votre chef associé christophe leroy lui
fait payer
dans mes pierre jean jé les menus menu
dîner club menu signature de saint marc
au menu je répondrai pas à ces questions
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas ça ne me
regarde pas je n'ai pas ce que je suis
pakistan turquie et argent je réorganise
et c'est bien sûr pas les miennes j'ai
fait deux présentations une en masse et
un vent de vendredi là on marre c'était
pour la presse a été publié et ses
ventes et là j'ai refait cette
présentation il y avait un petit peu
plus de gens justement pour faire venir
des chefs d'entreprise et des gens qui
chantent c'est tout mais on sent que
fous entre guillemets de cette histoire
c'est moi il ya eu 80 il ya eu 80
personnes pour faire un barbecue
j'étais à lyon ce week-end il y avait
des fêtes de partout ailleurs la vienne
me secourir quatre cents personnes sont
ce soir c'est là qu'ils gèlent
aujourd'hui chers camarades et bien
moins cher
gilles c'est celle que il était question
que j'ai des ministres je ne suis pas il
n'y avait pas le mini chaîne medi
d'argent l'avez vu vous avez c'est quasi
le ministre de l'intérieur ce matin il a
dit que ça allait quel est ton histoire
il ya les avoir en avoir il avoir une
enquête et vous savez que les
organisateurs cet événement rien entendu
il ya aucun problème car palin ministre
enfin c'est quand même associer les
ministres vont ils ont des salles à
manger chez eux ils sont des salles à
manger privée à l'elysée ils ont des
salles à manger tout le monde mon chez
eux ils n'ont pas à venir chez pierre et
son charme si on perd je suis quand la
seconde les amis et d'ailleurs certaines
personnes autour du plateau fait en tout
cas une personne est un de mes amis
vient souvent ceux qui à la maison je
n'ai jamais essayé cela dit c'est que tu
es mort d'amy mais ça me verges amis
enfin juste bergerat mois sergent
l'espoir aujourd'hui parce que tu sais
que ça peut aller très loin
on va de 15000 euros d'amendé et d'un an
de prison cette histoire de ses
conférences gastronomique appris appris
appris ses 7,7 thurnheer mais en dessous
en attendant je suis aussi sensible tous
les chefs d'entreprise tous les chefs de
pme y perdent aujourd'hui des millions
non mais des fortunes et caetera et
c'est catastrophique aujourd'hui durant
de l'argent je voulais te dire
des gens à ce que tu espères vont faire
attention l'accord qui on est en train
de raconter tout et n'importe quoi
j'espère genre est ce que tu es un peu
inquiet parce que quand on dit que ça
sente encourt une peine d'un an de
prison et 15000 euros d'amendé
tu vas être entendu prochainement par la
peau les écoutes je suis et je serai à
leur disposition il ya aucun problème
mais franchement c'est un cetain c'est
une tempête dans un verre d'eau enfin je
veux dire la liberté de la liberté de
parole la liberté de conscience
tu sais je vais dire un truc il ya là en
ce moment ça devient on est en train de
me dire j'ai l'impression d'être comme
une sorcière qu'on aurait affecté à la à
l'époque de la révolution ou des du
moyen-âge aurait été pendus haut et
court
donc si à un moment il faut il faut
arrêter quoi perdre dans ces saveurs je
sais j'ai une question à lui poser
quelques uns des droits je veux
quelqu'un de généreux que tu me connais
j'espère gens et par pierre-jean deux
amis sont franchement je suis une sorte
de bouc émissaire de cette histoire je
n'en reviens pas moi même si d'inviter
quelques personnes chez soir ça devient
je suis le nouveau jacques mesrine
c'est hallucinant plus ss j'ai
l'impression que ce serait peut-être en
train d'être repris par une certaine
partie de la classe politique de
certains extrêmes et c'est terry je sème
les gens je suis un homme généreux je
suis quelqu'un qui aime la vie
la semaine dernière j'ai encore fait je
le vends berges en leur genre plage en
juste dernière j'ai une petite question
à te poser pierre-jean comment parent de
plein d'associations
j'ai d'ailleurs aller les membres du
refuge à réunir dans quelques semaines
au palais liliane jeu pravail aps en
apollon pour l'histoire alors là on
essaie de me faire taire et en même
temps on essaye de faire taire napoléon
entre guy mer de l'est bicentenaire moi
je travaille pour l'amener à flers genre
et c'est ce que je vais dire un truc moi
je prends le métro toute ma vie et de ma
petite maman l'argent je les vis dans la
peau les ans quand je vais mourir
eh bien je donnerai la totalité de mes
ma collection à l'état français
je donne mon palais je donne mes
connexions à l'état français je me dis à
plusieurs fois alors faut arrêter de
dire que j'ai pas de maison à saint
tropez
j'ai pas deux paires genre à deux
voitures de but
j'ai pas de comptes andré nulle pa je
suis toujours fauché et j'aime les gens
et c'est aussi pour ça que je franchisse
bien jours jusqu'au pour résumer d'eau
père jean est
mais pas 40 personnes de ce que nous dit
pierre jean s'était pas payant et y
aller mais deux membres du gouvernement
c'est ce que dit le père jan est ce
qu'il est les jours des gens qui car
jean-pierre genre c'est pas facile
et toi merci si les gens justement
comment dirais-je j'ai une question se
pose est comment déclaration je ne parle
plus que franchement je suis les gens
sont bien sûrs d'eux les entend plus les
choses oui jean michel ce qui fait
vraiment scandale c'est pas tellement le
fait qu'il a organisé un dîner avec des
gens c'est qu'ils soient requis les mm
accord à l'amiable
je trouve le communiqué des pcistes un
peu fou il dit nous sommes en mesure de
confirmer qu'il y avait bien un ministre
qui disent qu'ils confirment cigs en
sont sûrs qu'ils en sont sûrs qu'ils
donnent le nom du ministre alors qu'il
se taise de the banner nous confirmant
sans donner un message à qui de
nombreuses pancartes et sur la wii alors
qu'il en est en train de dire en fête
qui se serait qui serait tombée dans un
mauvais piège de m6 m6 est en train dans
un guet-apens donc m6 est en train de se
défendre est en train de dire non à
l'unisson attention attention
pierre-jean challans hausses qui là
encore la pierre pire genre dernière
question au père jean
je sais que tu es très très bref je sais
que tu es très très très atteint par
cette histoire comment tu vas tu
il paraît que tu es vraiment et cette
voix là il est il est au bout de sa vie
et qu'il a connue en oreilles près du
micro ça fait un écran noir oui bonsoir
qu'est-ce que soit la tête et est
entouré tu es tu te sens comment tout
seul mais j'avoue que c'est un peu
compliqué j'avoue que tu sais je suis un
mec fort mais tu sais j'ai perdu mon
père l'année dernière j'ai perdu papa
l'année dernière j'ai perdu beaucoup de
nos amis cette année
j'ai eu comme ces insultes l'année
dernière tous les noms et là j'avoue que
c'est un peu fatigant et que voilà je je
vois là c'est pas facile voilà mais en
tout cas je te remercie mes amis vous
êtes tous adorables pire j'engage qu'on
va vite tourner la page
on va parler de choses importantes de
l'histoire des bicentenaires et voilà
parce que franchement là on est en train
de me dire est ce qu est ce qu un moment
t'as pas envie de dire voilà je vais
dire que je dis toute la vérité on
arrête cette histoire et arrêtez de me
saoulé je sais pas vous faites le si
s'il te plaît oui j'adorerais dire ça
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai
donc donc c'est je n'ai rien fait de mal
oui si je veux dire franchement si de
chance mais personne pourquoi père jean
pourquoi voudront pourquoi pourquoi bien
reconnaissait pas les dîners pourquoi
voir je reconnaissais pas avoir fait
payer des gens pour dîner tout
simplement les jeux les bâtis de ma
collection je suis un fils de on est au
bout de notre vie sociale
quelque chose bah oui moi je trouve ça
cette histoire incroyable parce que
effectivement soit il est avéré qu'il ya
eu une illégalité amis et dans ce cas là
c'est aux tribunaux d'en décider mais
c'est certainement pas le tribunal
médiatique d'exécuter quelqu'un de lui
mettre une telle pression alors qu'on
n'a pas de preuve patente si
effectivement m6 à un élément qu'ils le
sortent des quatre en tout état de cause
ça doit se régler
donc dans les mettre dans les tribunaux
et la deuxième chose c'est que c'est pas
en fait c'est pas lui le responsable
le responsable c'est le ministre qui
édicte des règles pour l'ensemble des
français et qui eux mêmes ne le
respectent et réparation